for a regional block fighting for
relevance it's a moment of decision for
ecowas
angered by Nigeria's co-leaders
resistance the group is now beating the
drums of War
it is activated its standby Force direct
the committee of the chief of Defense
staff
to activate the aqua standby force with
all its elements immediately
order the deployment
of the ecowas standby Force to restore
constitutional order in the Republic of
Niger
Nigeria's president who chairs the
organization is urging a united front
if we don't do it
no one else will do it for us
Echo stand by force made up of the
military police and civilians number
between three thousand to six thousand
depending on the crisis
it was deployed to The Gambia in 2017
when former president Yaya Jamie lost
the election and refused to hand over
its last deployment was to stabilize
guinea-bissau's political crisis
Echoes is back where it started two
weeks ago the threat of force and
diplomacy many series of religious
political crisis as important to the
survival of the regional block and its
relevance diplomas say failure to
resolve the situation may spill danger
not only to West Africa but the entire
continent
foreign
the announcement of a 21 member cabinet
by Nigeria's Junta may be the final blow
to resolving the crisis peacefully
the coup leaders have turned away all
missions sent by Echoes to negotiate an
end to the crisis
Ivory Coast Alaska is a vocal critic of
the coup they're keeping president
bazoom as a hostage
I personally consider this as a
terrorist Act and we cannot let this
continue
we have to act echo says it's committed
to diplomacy to resolve the crisis but
officials say time is running out
a source involved in mediation efforts
to end the crisis as Ninja's cool
leaders want concessions to begin talks
but diplomats fear seeding grounds to
the Junta could further weaken the
organization and encourage potential
cool plotters in the region Ahmed Idris
Al Jazeera Abuja